president Donald Trump is sounding newly
optimistic about Iran tremendous
progress was was made with Iran so we'll
see we'll see but it's all gonna work
out always does we get it to work out if
it doesn't sometimes it takes a little
longer but I get things to work out the
u.s. rhetoric in general on Iran has
taken it turns toward diplomacy the US
Secretary of State who initially accused
Iran of an act of war for last week's
attack that halved
Saudi Arabia's oil production now says
the u.s. seeks a diplomatic solution
above all you do want a peaceful
resolution of this that's our objective
president Trump and I both want to give
diplomacy every opportunity to succeed
but make no mistake about it if we were
unsuccessful in that and Iran continues
to strike out and that's why I'm
confident the president Trump will make
the decisions necessary to achieve our
objectives both Trump and Iran's
president Hassan rouhani planned to
attend a United Nations General Assembly
meeting this week but Trump says they
won't be talking to each other Ron
denies any role in the Saudi oil attacks
Houthi rebels in Yemen say they are
responsible and are vowing more tensions
have risen since the u.s. pulled out of
a 2015 nuclear agreement with Iran last
year the u.s. says its maximum pressure
campaign is working but there are a few
tangible signs of progress since then
'iron is shot down a US drone and the
u.s. is blamed Iran for attacks on oil
tankers and the Saudi oil site with the
United States sending hundreds of troop
reinforcements as well as anti-missile
defense systems to both Saudi Arabia and
the United Arab Emirates iran's Foreign
Minister sounds pessimistic I'm not
confident that we can avoid the war we
I'm confident that we will not start one
but I'm confident that whoever starts
one will not be the one who finishes it
so the standoff continues which both
sides say they want to end with words
not weapons Jon Hendren al Jazeera
Washington